most people want like really want all
the people I work with maybe the people
you work with what they really want
they'll never sit and they'll almost
never know it
what almost every human being wants
is they want to feel the day more
they got all these activities they're
blazing through get the kids to school
get this off of there get that done
answer that email get this party room
and even if they're moving towards
things they find meaningful and they're
awesome but if they don't feel it
if they're literally not present they're
not mindful enough to sense it to
appreciate to feel grateful to feel the
joy to feel the ups and feel the Downs
to feel the miseries to feel the winds
if you aren't feeling the day you're
just blazing through as an automaton
you're just blazing through the days you
know on autopilot you're just like
overwhelmed stress going through it but
you don't feel the day
I can't get you to be happy so the
gateway to all of happiness is always
presence learn to be more present